what's going on amy how can i help well
i would like some guidance on how i can
express my concerns to my sister
about her rapidly advancing relationship
her rapidly advancing relationship so is
she in love love with somebody that you
don't like
yes but there's a lot of details
surrounding it that are highly
concerning to me
okay go for it um well she discovered
in february that her husband of nine
years was having an affair
and with by the end of the month she had
made contact with new people
and um found a person from her past
she didn't really know well but like you
know over 15 years ago she knew this
person and um
within a week they had met again we live
on opposite sides of the country
so she flew across the country to meet
this person and then within a week
or a week and a half after that they're
professing love for each other
and he's planning to move in with her
um and she has two small children and
he's going to move
all the way back across the country to
go move in with her and her children and
i'm just like
and my husband and i met him also and
all of our
sirens are going off that this is like
not a person we trust
hey this dude this guy won the lottery
man some old girlfriend reached out to
him and is like hey you want
free free rent and me and he was like
okay okay
yeah this works out great for him huh
right
right and he's like he's um eight or
nine years older than her
he seems kind of a mess you know he he
rents an apartment with some other
person who kind of
seems to want him out um and then my
sister comes in and i don't even
last i talked to her she still hadn't
filed divorce papers yet
um her current husband has already moved
out and so she's just ready to move this
guy
right in yeah and of course being the
sister that i am
i went down to the courthouse and looked
up his records and
um i didn't find things that were great
and i even discovered a lawsuit where he
was sued for
basically not getting out of a place i
don't know the details surrounding but
all of it's very concerning and she has
a two and a four-year-old
and i'm just i don't want her to think
that i am not happy for her
i'm worried if i say something or i
don't want to say something wrong you
know where
where he'll tell her manipulate her and
make her think oh they're just jealous
of our love
that kind of thing yeah wow that's a
mess
um how long was your sister marry for
uh i think about nine years okay yeah
you said that
how good is y'all's relationship i think
it's really good we're really close
so have you when you've kind of hinted
around this
or asked like really well this is what
we're doing
how she responded um
i think i've raised a few concerns um
she's kind of in a mode where she's not
like herself she's
she's very much like a different person
and i think she just thinks
it's it's hard for people to understand
so she's like
okay you know it's just it's really hard
for people to wrap their their minds
around
you know the fact that i'm in love and
i've got this fairytale man
and you know and i like i don't know i
don't think that's so
what man okay so here's a couple things
i i would throw out for her sake
and then here's
i'll just i'll give you some of my
thoughts here i'm smiling because
everyone who falls in love especially
after a heartbreak
or a tragedy they look around
and it's so intoxicating that they
think everyone else is crazy and it's so
hard because
as someone who loves someone in that
situation we often just have to ride it
out
right it just and it's so painful
because you know how it's going to end
you know how it's going to end right
yeah
so um sometimes i give people a pass
on the quick turnaround time after
something like this and here's why
there are chances that her marriage has
been
dead for years yeah and it may have
or been on life support for years and so
she may have
um had one foot one half of her heart
two feet out the door and not even
realized it for a long long time
and then it just takes something like
this big reveal which she may have known
about
um maybe not intellectually but she knew
in her soul or
she did know about it or she just
blindsided right which makes this a
super trauma the whole thing's traumatic
regardless but it may have been dead for
a long time so often when we see
a this is different than somebody passes
away in a car wreck right
um where it literally just snap your
fingers is over
this may have been running for a long
time that still doesn't make this
wise at all right so my question for you
is what is your um
or what statement here so
let's say you get the courage and it
would be hard right you get the courage
you go sit down with her you look her in
the eye and say i think you're making a
terrible mistake
absolutely bonkers terrible mistake and
she says i hate you you're the worst
sister ever you've never loved me or
supported me in fact my husband cheated
on me because it's your fault i mean
just
all the stuff she could throw at you
what is your or what statement are you
gonna
disassociate yourself from her are you
going to back down from her
or are you just feeling powerless right
now because you're going to still love
her she's still going to be your sister
you're still going to hang out with her
and you're just watching a slow-motion
car wreck which one of those is it
no it's definitely the latter okay so
you don't have like an
or what or if then statement no
okay so if somebody's at a point where
i'm about to draw a real firm boundary
that i know
might really impact this relationship
in a negative way um that's one
conversation
this conversation is a little bit
different it's a little bit easier and a
little bit
harder for you okay here's my
recommendation
i would take her out somewhere and
get her to tell you about this guy why
is he so wonderful
and you can ask the gentle questions
about
this seems super fast and i'm concerned
and i love you
and then the final statement i learned
this from one of my counseling
professors dr hendricks and i love it
which is i'm worried about you and your
future
but you're a grown-up and i want you to
know i'm going to be
here when things are great i'm going to
be here when things are hard
and i'm going to be here if things
completely fall apart
and and and i'm always going to be
concerned for those kids
and so if you ever need anything let me
know and what that does is it
it rings a bell for some folks that
you're not trying to judge them
that you are literally walking alongside
them and you just recognize that they
let your hand go and
some folks are like okay whatever dude
but then they remember that when things
fall apart and it may be two months
three months seven months
um or seven years but that you will be
the first call they can make
and beyond that there's not a lot you
can do which is really really scary
um do you think this guy is unsafe for
those kids or is he just look like a bum
i don't know i i don't i wouldn't let
him around my children
um okay so why not why not
um that's a bold statement i told her
that if if they come and you know visit
you know who's gonna move in than they
were because she lives in arizona i'm in
north carolina
oh so you're far apart okay right so and
he lives here in north carolina so he's
moving out there with her
so they had talked about coming to visit
this summer we said of course they can
stay with us
but then after we met him i there's i
can't put my finger on it
but both my husband and i were like we
can visit with him
we can have a cookout with him he is not
staying in our home
um and we're not generally closed off
like that but we have four kids
and i'm like i wouldn't trust him near
my children
and so so what is it what's the thing
what's the thing i i wouldn't
thousand percent trust your intuition
here right i i
never push back on this intuition but
i'm i'm wondering what is it
i think part of it i mean there's
something about his
essence or something and part of it is
the control he's
he's been able to um you know
kind of exert over my sister and make
her very different
and she's my older sister she's always
been responsible very financially
independent very intelligent
um and he's had this effect on her and
i'm you know she's behaved differently
around her own children
you know when i when i hear her talk to
them and it's just concerning that
what could happen in that home now that
boyfriend's kind of the center in the
obsession
um i i just worry yeah like it would i
don't know i'm like would they be taken
care of like
could he hurt them you know so so
yeah my mom's signals are going crazy
yeah and
all the things you just said are are the
answer is yes he could hurt him
and if their mom is i love the
he's a drug right now right she's
grieving he's a drug
and if mom is willing to
do drugs with kids in the house then
yeah
he could hurt him he's gonna have access
so yes
as your sist as her sister as the um
as a responsible citizen right as their
aunt
yeah you gotta keep that antenna up you
know to make sure that things are
they're safe and that you're not hearing
anything bonkers or weird and
um they're so so little and so young
right it's not like you can
call them on a side conversation like if
they were teenagers
um so based on that i might have a
little more direct conversation with her
a little more
a little harder conversation about hey
what are you doing
this is not smart not wise and maybe
tell her i love you so much i'm willing
to
um cause a rift in our relationship
right now
but this is not smart not why is it not
safe you don't know this guy
and moving in is too soon too fast right
you could try that it's probably not
going to work it's probably going to be
messy
um but at least when this thing starts
getting the rail stuff coming off she'll
know that you love her
but again sometimes if you make yourself
so unsafe she'll feel like she's got no
one to call
right but we are just so i'm
i'm more interested in a long-term
relational play here but
um yeah i
at the end of the day you can't do
anything about this that's that's the
hard part
you can have a gentle conversation you
can have a flexed conversation you can
have an
angry i'm the aunt of these kids i don't
trust this guy something about him
it's not ringing true to me it's not
safe what are you doing
any three of those situations may work
they probably won't
and what you're going for now is a
long-term relational play like i said so
that she reaches out to you when when
things go sideways which they probably
will
and if you ever get a hint an inkling
any sort of as you said
i love it any sort of essence that the
kids aren't safe
that they aren't doing okay that they're
being neglected they're being treated
bad
you call every alarm that you know you
call every person
every community member every police
officer you call everybody
and make sure those kids are safe and
taken care of okay
i hate this for you and your family this
is hard this is a mess
stay with your sister and make sure that
she knows that you love her
and and take care of yourself because
this is going to get heavy so you and
your husband
instead of sitting over there just
having all these judgment conversations
that guy sucks and what she do in our
check in with each other hey how are you
doing on this because i know this is
hard i know you love your sister
and give each other spaces to be
frustrated give each other spaces to be
sad and degree of this
and then to go about controlling things
you can control and you can't control
knuckleheaded older sisters for sure
thank you so much for that call amy